activate anti boob-ie suits
total waste the snakes
it's been way too long
good idea Morty openness to these
asteroids sooner the smartest Rick and
Marty is Morty in the universe are back
I'm not rated to climb something this
sheer, look you're the guy that wanted an
epic adventure I'm the guy with only one
hover chair and things are pretty much
the same people who are really
I don't know I'm just usually around
people that faster Rick and Morty
five all-new episode starts Sunday
November 10th at 11:30 half the season
you deserve all the season we could
handle you know what this one counts as
one of your adventures only on Adult
Swim brought to you by Wendy's
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new Rick and Morty season
4 episode 3 video they just dropped some
new footage with a whole bunch of Easter
eggs so we'll break it down there's a
new round of that Rick and Morty merch
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite moment from the season so far
so at the beginning of this scene
they're entering this ancient alien
temple to find some sort of lost
treasure or something that the temple
hides or this dungeon but because of the
way the show always tries to make fun of
science fiction and fantasy tropes Rick
whips out special suits made to make
them immune from all the very trophy
dungeon traps the builders left behind
and because they're booby traps of
course Rick calls them anti booby suits
which also kind of feels like a meta
joke in real life about the writers
making fun of a certain group of people
if you get my meaning but part of the
joke of them making fun of all these
tropes from big action movies and
science fiction is that the aliens that
built the dungeon seem very advanced
look at the statues that look like
droids themselves they look like the b1
battle droids from Star Wars attack of
the clones and clone wars the joke that
Rick would make about something like
this is that you have this whole trope
of dungeons and booby traps is that the
dungeon in the traps are super low fight
echnology for a very advanced seeming
race like it completely doesn't make
sense why would a super technologically
advanced race build an old-timey dungeon
when they could build traps and
countermeasures that are way more
advanced than any of the things that
look like they're straight out of an
Indiana Jones movie it in fact all of
the different traps that they walk
through all the different scenes in this
clip are from Indiana Jones movies when
they walk through the first section
where all the darts come out after they
step on the traps that's from Raiders of
the Lost Ark then in the next section
they walk through this doorway their
suits deflect giant pointed stone rocks
like they're nothing
normally it would a split Rick's heading
to also look in the background here
notice all the electronic panels glowing
on the walls like this seems like an old
timey stone building but yet somehow it
has electronics running all the way
through it the animators have been doing
a fantastic job this season - if Yuri
watch the episodes a couple times you
start to notice more things that they
draw into the background they don't
necessarily have a lot to do with what
Rick and Morty are actually doing
they're just cool Easter eggs there was
someone that told me that Justin roiland
for example it doesn't always
about all the stuff that the animators
put in episodes like he'll usually be
around for most things but every once in
a while one of the animators will just
sneak stuff into the background just for
fun you look in the foreground you see
all these would be other alien treasure
hunters one of them wearing a breathing
apparatus his face in the design of his
character are kind of giving me a
Prometheus alien Series vibe if he
didn't watch Prometheus it's not one of
the good alien movies but it was a
prequel attempting to answer the
question of where the Xenomorphs came
from and in it the crew finds this
ancient alien ship buried underground
that kind of looks similar to the design
of this dungeon really old-timey in
ancient yet hyper advanced compared to
modern technology all of you probably
got this next reference the next trap is
the boulder coming out of the side door
and bouncing right off of Rick one of
the most famous Indiana Jones Raiders of
the Lost Ark bits then the final trap in
the clip is the snakes also a longtime
Indiana Jones movie trope I hate snakes
it started in Raiders of the Lost Ark
but then when they did the flashbacks
during Last Crusade they explained why
he'd always been so afraid of snakes the
whole reason that they're at this
dungeon probably has something to do
with the heist theme of the episode like
in the episode 3 trailer they released a
couple days ago they're doing an Ocean's
eleven bit where Rick plays the George
Clooney character assembling this squad
of former criminals or friends for a gig
most of them based on Ocean's eleven
characters this one I guess you could
say is a bit of a ghost in the shell'
reference to the woman with the hands
that just separate as they're typing on
the keyboards whatever is going on with
your confusing ass hands then they all
show up in what seems like this heist
convention with the bank vault behind
them they ask what the actual job is
that he needed them for and the real bit
is that he actually only needed them to
roll in with him for the montage and
that was it
cue the Spongebob meme I'm out of here
Rick and Morty as a show making fun of
science fiction and movie TV Tropes
isn't a new thing they do that in every
single episode
it's just that in this episode in
particular and all the promos that
they've released they're doing much more
overt parodies of specific movies like
Indiana Jones and Ocean's eleven it's
kind of like The Vindicators Episode
where it's very specifically making fun
of Marvel and DC movies the writers of
their own press releases Morty they're a
bunch of drama queens it's been an hour
talking and 20 minutes jumping around
while shit blows up
they're a phase we did one it was the
big event of that summer it's not really
clear why they need to go to this heist
convention but aside from his scene
where Rick is pissed and uses a
grappling hook to escape and steal this
ship from all these aliens who
themselves are also stealing stuff from
this building in the scenes of him
assembling his crew earlier in the
trailer in all the other scenes he's got
that same board look on his face like he
could care less about what they're doing
at any given moment even in the Doctor
Strange ripoff joke lab coat ripoff
Doctor Strange wear his coat strangles
the security guard at the convention
like dr. Strange's cloak of levitation
strangles his enemies look at his face
he's still got that same look of
absolutely not caring about what's going
on in their current situation he uses
his technology to walk right through the
security guard he doesn't even slow down
or bother to walk around him these are
all examples of one of my favorite
long-running Rick and Morty gags season
two season
the idea that Rick has modified his body
has closed all the things he carries
around with him to such an extent that
it almost makes him invincible like when
he's fighting toxic Rick in season 3 not
only does he have weapons stashed all
over the house and common items in
places things you would never think
would hold weapons but he's also got
that special belt buckle security device
and even better taking it up a notch in
season 3 episode 10 when he's inside the
White House in the secret servicemen
tries to touch him he tells me you
better not you're going to and there's
no afterlife everything just goes black
of course because this is Rick and Morty
he doesn't believe him touches them
instantly drops dead and everyone in the
room just completely loses it even Morty
not really sure what's going on all
because as he goes on to narrate in the
speech right after that the writers
write him so that he could literally do
anything at the drop of a hat to keep
him completely unpredictable in any
given situation you have no idea who I
am he even refers to himself like Doctor
Who making the character that way makes
a lot easier to write really crazy
scenes because at this point this many
seasons into it it makes a lot more
sense that he's capable of doing
anything in any given situation which is
just really good for comedy you could
also tie all of his personal security
measures back to the theme of episode 2
that he's kind of afraid to let anyone
get
close to him and as part of the reason
why he builds such elaborate personal
security devices even if he doesn't
really need them just to keep regular
people away as much as they're there to
keep enemies away this is that clip of
Dan and Justin talking about that the
toilet episode is just an exploration of
Rick's isolation starting with something
a lot of people can relate to which is
being a shy pooper he has a secret
pooping place the thing that I love is
showing how lonely rick is and then his
rejection of friendship from someone who
really is like a good person you're not
going to me what it turns into a story
about Rick's capacity for friendship I
have a million cooler friends than you
I'll be seeing you I think also just the
shock of this person dying it just kind
of I think it further cements Rick as
this lonely person who's never going to get
close to anybody you know it's like why
bother thinking about what they said
it's easy to understand how Rick would
create so much crazy technology just to
push other people away but let me know
in the comments what's your favorite
scene of Rick using surprise weapons
that he carries on himself that he just
whips out on a dime to get out of
situations my full episode 3 video will
post Monday morning just like normal I'm
also working on a new Mandalorian video
that will post next name a giveaway
winner when I post that episode video
everyone click here for my Rick and
Morty season 3 episode 2 video and click
here for my Mandalorian episode 3 video
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight!